voici les vestiges de la ligne m'arrête
en tunisie
c'est là que le maréchal erwin rommel
livre à son dernier combat en afrique
alors qu'une puissante force britannique
se rapprocher inexorablement du dernier
carré de l'afrika korps le renard du
désert donne à ses ultimes ordre de
bataille depuis cette position lorsqu'il
occupait cette portion de terrain en
mars 1943
les hommes de l'afrika korps se
regardaient la défaite en face les
armées alliées se rapprochait de toutes
parts et il devenait évident pour les
hommes qui servait ses défenses très
bien construite que la fin était proche
c'était le dernier acte d'une force
devenu légendaire l'afrika korps
la véritable histoire de l'afrika korps
l'afrika korps était le symbole de tout
ce que la machine de guerre allemande
avait produit de meilleur dans sa brève
histoire seulement 2 ans et 3 - l'afrika
korps entraîna les forces alliées dans
une massif guerre d'usure et gagna pour
elle même une réputation enviable dans
les annales de l'histoire militaire
grâce à une série de plans de bataille
brillamment exécuté son célèbre chef le
maréchal erwin rommel méritas le surnom
de renard du désert
il était respecté autant par ses hommes
que par ses adversaires
en fait je pense que la réputation de
rebelle l'était celle du jeune allemand
du leader chevaleresque des guerres du
désert des renards du désert comme on
l'appelait and ancient et en un sens on
a forcé le trait sur cette image
indubitablement c'était un très bon chef
est un très bon meneur de chars en
particulier qui devint une sorte de
héros
erwin rommel avait d'autres facettes
yvon il fut un grand propagandiste de sa
propre carrière
il avait quelques liens avec le parti
nazi dont certains n'ont pas encore été
révélés à ce jour et il y avait des
failles dans sa pensée militaire
elle n'était peut-être pas si évidente
que cela au moment où il combattait les
britanniques en afrique du nord
les britanniques sont très forts pour
hisser au rang de héros ceux qui les ont
vaincus ils l'ont fait avec des groupes
tribaux comme les zoulous les guerres
curse ils le feront pour des hommes
comme rebelles qui les avait battus
comme elle fut très chanceux de
remporter sa première victoire majeure
en mars 1941 dans une période où rien de
mieux ne se passait or rom elle avait
besoin de victoires en monstre mal
compris quelle était l'importance
d'avoir une bonne publicité et à quel
point il est nécessaire de gagner la
bataille politique
même pour un général ivan zamorano
en 1940 la wehrmacht était
singulièrement mal équipé pour le combat
sous le soleil brûlant d'afrique du nord
les formations militaires allemandes
avaient été créés pour le terrain
européen
il n'avait pas une seule unité
spécifiquement entraînés au combat dans
le désert à l'inversé les britanniques
avaient des années d'expérience dans le
désert datant d'avant la première guerre
mondiale
les britanniques étaient restés actifs
en afrique du nord depuis napoléon et
maintenait une présence permanente en
egypte
durant les premières années de la
seconde guerre mondiale les anglais
avaient remporté une série de succès
régulier contre les forces italiennes en
afrique du nord
soucieux de soutenir son allié mussolini
hitler signala directif et rhône au
numéro 22
nom de code opération sonne blum
tournesol en français qui programmait
l'envoi de petites unités allemandes à
tripoli pour aider les italiens à
bloquer la vente des britanniques and
banking
en décembre 1940 les forces britanniques
du désert occidental alors sous le
commandement du général ce richard
connor emprunt entame l'opération
compass cette opération commencée par un
raid de cinq jours s'achevait finalement
le 5 février 1941 dans la bataille de
bedford et la destruction complète de la
10ème armées italiennes
la décision d'envoyer des troupes
allemandes en afrique du nord fut prise
début janvier 1941 pour contrer la
banque britannique à ne jamais à aucun
moment dans l'idée que cette force
défensive pourrait devenir une unité
opérationnelle en marche vers l'egypte
et qui essaierait peut-être de prendre
le caire ce n'était tout simplement pas
dans les plantes en garde les premiers
allemands acheminés par navire vers
l'italie furent ceux de la cinquième
division légère constitué d'un bataillon
de reconnaissance antichars et d'un
autre d'artillerie légère
il était soutenu par un détachement
composé d'une compagnie de transmission
et d'une de génie l'unité fut par la
suite rebaptisé 21e panzer division et
devint l'une des plus fameuses forces de
combat de la seconde guerre mondiale
romane n'avait été rappelé de permission
pour prendre le commandement de cette
force
la traversée maritime l'amena à tripoli
le 14 février 1941 elle fut rapidement
renforcée par le 5e régiment de panzers
par la 15e panzer division et par la 90e
division légère
toutes ces nouvelles formations furent
rapidement assemblés à partir de
fragments de précédentes division de
plus il y avait un soutien aérien fourni
par des bombardiers en piqué chtouka et
les chasseurs messerschmidt opérant
depuis des aérodromes en sicile les
soldats eux-mêmes étaient issus de tous
les horizons de la wehrmacht
mais pour la plupart hors de l'influencé
des cadres politiques des ss ou de la
gestapo qui émaillaient les autres
formations allemandes
il en résulte que dans l'histoire de
l'afrika korps jamais il n'eut
d'exactions ni d'activités répressive du
aux unités d'extermination de la police
secrète mais affecte l'afrika korps des
buts a vraiment la campagne d'afrique
entre février mars 1941 les débuts à
partir de cette date au plus fort de
l'action l'afrika korps étaient
présentes quel que soit le lieu où se
déroulaient les combats l'afrika korps
comme son nom le suggérer ce n'était
qu'un corps d'armée semonce était une
force relativement réduite avec deux
pointures division est en fait la
seconde compte sur division n'arriva pas
avant mai 1941
c'était une division légère la 90e
division et ce sans artillerie lourde
à cela s'ajoutait deux unités italiennes
de taille honorable
au final il s'agissait d'une force peu
consistante
les hommes de l'afrika korps se
battirent durement mais il croyait en
les lois de la guerre qu'il pratiquait
la guerre du désert fut souvent décrite
comme le dernier exemple d'une guerre
chevaleresque
quoi qu'il en soit ce fut un
affrontement très dur
par une série de reconnaissances et
claire remet à l'établi rapidement que
les forces alliées lancé contre lui
avaient été surestimées
il faisait face à la 2e division de
l'armée de terre nouvellement arrivées
de grande bretagne est pas encore
acclimaté au désert la 2e division
blindée étaient composés d'une brigade
blindée affaibli armés de chars usées et
sans soutien logistique
elle était appuyée par la 9e division
australienne tout aussi affaiblie une
troisième formation britannique
stationner en réserve à tobrouk
ces forces étaient commandées par le
général web les troupes de wons ça avait
été réquisitionné par les unités
stationnées en crète puis en grèce
depuis janvier 1941 et lorsque l'afrique
accord se finit par frapper en mars 1941
il ne restait plus qu'une troupe très
réduite face à elle les britanniques qui
avaient balayé les italiens se trouvait
au bout d'une chaîne logistique
extrêmement longues qui ne pouvaient
plus soutenir depuis l'egypte
les nombreuses tout langage est loin
dans le désert occidental de plus on
afrika korps était bien commander les
hommes étaient très motivés ils avaient
de très bons chars et les véhicules
d'artillerie pour lutter contre les
équipements britanniques les allemands
s'étaient entraînés et avait développé
les concepts de guerre de mobilité un
stade très poussée pendant les campagnes
de france et de pologne
ce qui signifiait que l'afrika korps
était une force très équilibré où chaque
arme étant capable de s'adapter à tous
les terrains et d'affronter n'importe
quel adversaire
alors que rebelles lancé ces attaques en
cyrénaïque il devint tout à fait clair
qu'il possède l avantage de la qualité
de son armement au 22 chars cruiser et
25 chars légers britannique le 5e
régiment de panzers opposait plus de 150
chars dont près de la moitié étaient des
panzers 3 et panzer 4 bien supérieures
de plus romel possédait déjà des canons
de 88 mm antiaériens qu'il pouvait
utiliser avec un effet dévastateur
contre des cibles terrestres
là où les britanniques tendait à
utiliser leurs chars indépendamment des
autres armes
enfin cros les allemands avaient
développé une coordination très serré
entre leurs chars l'artillerie mobile et
l'infanterie cela on faisait des
adversaires bien plus dur est compact
lors des combats dans le désert
une des raisons du succès tactiques de
romaine résidait dans son usage
systématique de la technique data qui
consistait à envoyer ses chars contre
les chars ennemis en attaque frontale
lorsque les charrs alliés mordait à
l'hameçon en chargeant du panzer
ceux-ci se réfugier derrière une rangée
de canon de 88 mm qui a plus grande
portée pouvait les engagés avec un taux
de coups au but décisif elle se rendit
compte très vite que plutôt que
d'envoyer ses chars contre les chars
ennemis sont meilleurs moyens de
détruire les blindés étaient ses canons
antichars bleus mieux pour lui était
donc de pousser les britanniques attaqué
son infanterie ou c# et de les attirer
sur ses positions anti char c'est une
technique qui l'utilisa encore et encore
et que les britanniques ne réussira
jamais à contrer affecte le désert
d'afrique du nord fut décrit comme le
paradis des stratèges et l'enfer des
logisticiens
pour un penseur progressiste comme
romaine c'était un paradis grâce à ses
vastes étendues inhabitées sans
changement de saison sans groupes de
résistance ni partisan centres urbains
pour ralentir les mouvements de ses
divisions blindées
mais pour les hommes en charge du
soutien logistique c'était un pur
cauchemar parce que tout le carburant
les munitions la nourriture les armes
devaient être acheminés par des lignes
de ravitaillement qui s'étirait à
l'extrême à mesure que l'afrika korps
déferlé vers l'est en tout le
ravitaillement de l'armée de rebelles en
termes de munitions de carburant et de
nourriture et tout ce dont une armée a
besoin était acheminée d'italie qui
transportait les navires marchands
italiens devaient relever le défi du
passage de l'île britannique de malte
avec leurs sous marins et leurs avions
basés sur la côte ouest en ligne à un
jet d'eau bien que ce trajet soit
relativement court à peine soixante
mille ans c'était une ligne de
ravitaillement très vulnérables aux
attaques britannique le ravitaillement
devait ensuite être transporté à terre
par la seconde d'afrique du nord non la
b abu diab et a construit par les italie
heinz 1 0 en 11 ans alors que l'armée de
rebelles avançaient vers l'est
six voies de ravitaillement s'étirer au
point qu'en 1942 romaine atteint el
alamein à seulement 96 kilomètres
d'alexandrie
on essaie avec une ligne logistique de
plus de 2000 kilomètres depuis tripoli
bien sûr un des gros problèmes en
opérant sur ses longues distances et que
les camions eux mêmes brûle de carburant
entre 10 et 15% de tout ce que l'afrika
korps consommer et est utilisée par les
véhicules de ravitaillement dans ce
genre de conditions sur ces routes très
rudimentaire qui détérioraient assez
vite les véhicules les pannes étaient
inévitables
ap thomas schaaf à n'importe quel moment
30% environ des véhicules de rebelles
était en réparation
les britanniques l'aidèrent énormément
en abandonnant leur véhicule derrière
eux
hindemith et fax par du coup à l'été
1942 tout le transport logistique de
l'afrika korps était pratiquement
assurée avec des camions anglais comme
les alliés avant tel l'afrika korps
réalise rapidement que les limitations
géographiques à l'est la force et à
opérer à l'intérieur d'une bande de
terrain de 80 km vers le sud
à partir de la côte jusqu'aux dunes de
sable qui s'étendait à l'infini vers le
désert profond impraticable pour les
véhicules à roues ou à chenilles dans
cette bande de 80 km il n'y avait qu'une
seule route la vie à bâle bien qui
longeait la côte
les chars de romaine ainsi que ces
colonnes de camions logistiques
circulait sur cette artère de bitume le
carburant était l'une des plus
précieuses denrées
il était toujours rationnée et toute
utilisation non autorisée d'un véhicule
était sévèrement punis le terrain en
afrique du nord était particulièrement
difficile
bien qu'on ait tendance à imaginer de
grandes dunes de sable une grande partie
de ce désert était en fait un désert de
pierres et de rocailles fit payer un
lourd tribut non seulement aux hommes
mais aussi aux véhicules
les chenilles de chars se tordait et les
pneus étaient lacérés sur ce type de
terrain
transpole est sain le sable ou soulevées
par le constant déplacement des
véhicules entre à sel et filtrer les
lubrifiants nécessaires au bon
fonctionnement des moteurs étaient
consommés en bien plus grande quantité
ces conditions nécessitait une manoeuvre
très important triste
initialement les panzers était arrivé
avec des filtres air européen normaux
inévitablement le sable pénétrait à
travers ces filtres et atteignait les
cylindres des moteurs au point de les
bloquer avant les 1500 premiers
kilomètres
ensemble les allemands et les italiens
en afrique du nord avait besoin de plus
de 70 mille tonnes de ravitaillement
chaque mois tous venaient par la mer
depuis des ports d'italie méridionale et
tous les convois subissaient les
attaques de la royal navy et de la royal
air force
de petites quantités d'approvisionnement
étaient acheminés par air de temps en
temps mais les junker 52 de transport
n'était pas armé ni disponibles en
nombre suffisant et dans tous les cas
constituer des cibles faciles pour les
hurricanes aux maraudes
en vendée bien que l'afrique accord est
à faire face à d'énormes difficultés
logistiques
il n'était pas question qu'elles tombent
à court de ravitaillement mais celui ci
n'arrivait jamais en quantité suffisante
il est intéressant d'observer les
statistiques des équipements expédié qui
arrive est réellement à destination elle
montre que 90 % des hommes véhicules et
approvisionnement envoyé atteignait
l'afrika korps il ya bien sûr l'argument
de dire que beaucoup de ravitaillement
qui aurait dû être envoyés ne l'ont
jamais été manassas je peux l'accepter
mais il y avait de toute évidence un
flux régulier d'approvisionnement qui
n'était pas aussi faible que ce que l'on
peut bien laisser croire aux mâles
étaient désireux d'avancer aussi loin
qu'ils le pourraient aussi rapidement
que possible
il avait un point de mire le canal de
suez
son objectif final fréquemment ces
lignes de ravitaillement étaient étirées
à la limite de la rupture
mais c'était un homme indifférent aux
limitations imposées par cette situation
malgré le fait qu'il se trouve à la
frontière égyptienne à plus de 1200
kilomètres de son principal port de
ravitaillement à tripoli romel considéré
que la logistique était une tâche qui
relevait du haut commandement
son travail était de combattre
ravitailler l'armée n'était selon ses
propres mots pas son problème
le principal problème de rebelles avec
son haut commandement était qu'il
estimait qu'il s'agissait d'un théâtre
d'opérations à part entière alors que le
haut commandement considéré qu'il
n'était qu'une partie d'une stratégie
d'ensemble beaucoup plus large
romane ne pouvait pas être d'accord avec
leur vision le mythe de romell
grandissait faisant de lui une sorte de
super héros ou de chevalier blanc du
désert au moose en était devenu presque
automatique que les gens prennent parti
d'autant que ses supérieurs qui était
d'ailleurs de très bon officier en face
était en lutte avec cet énorme ce tigre
qu'ils avaient attrapé par la queue
c'est à dire la russie avait besoin de
toutes les ressources disponibles du
second semestre 1942 ils se trouvèrent
dans un cercle vicieux les menant pour
désastre de staline grave et l'air
d'avoir quelqu'un dans le désert qui
soit en mesure d'attirer le plus de
forces alliées possible mais romaine
était malvenu de débarquer avec ses
plans fantaisistes pour prendre le caire
fans qui lui poussait plus avant jusqu'à
faire la jonction avec le groupement
d'armé sud dans le caucase quand les
soldats débarquer à tripoli
il n'avait pas la moindre idée des
conditions auxquelles ils allaient
devoir faire face en europe le menu de
base des soldats était composée de pins
et de patates dans le désert il était
évident que ces aliments aller vite
moisir ils furent donc remplacés par des
biscuits et des haricots
occasionnellement agrémenté de petites
portions de fromage de légumes
déshydraté et de boîte de viande
italiennes dont l'origine a toujours été
un sujet de débat parmi les soldats les
hommes de l'afrique accorde ce subissait
ce régime monotone avec peu de vitamine
c
en comparaison les soldats alliés vivait
presque dans l'opulence avec des fruits
et légumes en conserves du pain blanc et
l'inévitable quand beef le rêve de
chaque soldat de l'afrika korps était de
capturer le ravitaillement à lier ces
images tirées du magazine de propagande
signal illustre parfaitement les
distances que les soldats allemands
étaient prêts à parcourir pour se
procurer des rations britannique
provenant d'un navire de ravitaillement
endommagé la pénurie d'eau était
également un grand problème et il
n'était pas inhabituel pour les camions
d'effectuer des voyages de 500 km pour
en récupérer la très forte luminosité du
soleil dans le désert imposer ses
propres règles à la conduite des
opérations en afrique du nord les hommes
souffrent souvent d'une forme de cécité
il fut établi qu'entre l'aube et 9
heures du matin et entre 4 heures de
l'après midi le crépuscule un homme
pouvait identifier avec précision un
véhicule amis ou ennemis à une distance
de 2000 à 5000 m en pleine chaleur
cette portée était de 1300 mètres
environ la tombée de la nuit mais tu est
généralement un terme aux combats de
blindés mais pas nécessairement à leur
mouvement
les équipages des panzers avait appris à
lire un conte pas leur permettant de
circuler de nuit et même en plein milieu
des tempêtes de sable les équipages de
dépannage allemand était prêt à
reprendre l'avantagé dès la fin de la
nuit pour récupérer les charrs
endommagées et les envoyer vers
l'arrière pour les réparer il en
profitait aussi pour dynamiter les
véhicules de commandement où les charrs
alliés qui avaient été laissés
abandonner sur le champ de bataille
le problème crucial des
approvisionnements de l'afrika korps
faisaient de la réparation des chars
endommagé une nécessité impérative afin
de combler le désavantage numérique face
aux forces alliées remet elle faisait
partie de cette poignée de commandants
qui cherchait toujours à constater
personnellement ce qui se passait ils
pensaient qu'ils devaient avoir un oeil
sur la bataille entre à affi n'guessan
donc il se devait d'être là en personne
pendant les combats
cela signifiait que romane et est du
coup souvent capables de réagir plus
rapidement aux événements parce que ses
homologues britanniques qui se reposait
sur la chaîne de commandement
mais dans le même temps cela voulait
dire que rebelle laisser son chef d'état
major et son quartier général à quelques
kilomètres derrière lui lorsqu'il
faisait le tour du champ de bataille
avec son semi chauny est personnel ils
avaient un bon système de communication
radio mais il était souvent brouillée
par les britanniques
c'était dans la nature des choses les
communications radio était à l'époque
problématique et ses commandants ne
savait pas où leur chef se trouvait
réellement à tripoli le désert l'art de
la dissimulation et du camouflage fut un
talent rapidement acquis par les hommes
de l'afrika korps
lorsque les premiers panzer 2 3 et 4
arrivèrent il n'était pas avec le gris
vert de la wehrmacht bien trop visible
dans le désert en l'absence de toute
peinture aux couleurs du désert
ces premiers chars furent aspergé
d'huile et ensuite on les recouvrir
entièrement de sable si bien qu'il
pouvait facilement se fondre dans le
paysage
les tankistes apprirent vite à se servir
de filet de camouflage et des buissons à
chameau pour casser les silhouettes de
leurs chars
les artilleurs de 20 experts pour
enterrer leurs armes s'ils n'arrivaient
pas à creuser le sable ils faisaient
sauter les roches au tour pour créer un
an bossemans et avec les canons pointés
à l'horizontale il n'y avait de la vie
de romain lui même rien de visible
pour l'infanterie le filet de camouflage
avait deux buts dans les étroites
tranché ils les cachaient de la vue de
leurs ennemis et leur apporter une
certaine protection contre la chaleur du
soleil
bien souvent les hommes de l'afrika
korps avait assez peu de temps pour
creuser leur tranchée car la tactique de
rebelles était toujours une combinaison
d'infanterie d'artillerie et de chars
si bien que toutes les armes du corps
saints étaient utilisés conjointement
faisant un effort maximum pour effectuer
des offensives concentré bien qu'ils
aient tué à parcourir de larges régions
sans relief l'énergie inépuisable de
rebelles tirer les hommes vers le haut
lorsqu'il n'était pas à bord de son
véhicule de commandement baptisé crac
remet elle reconnaissait le terrain
depuis le cockpit de son fils leur store
un avion d'observation à partir duquel
ils pressaient ses troupes d'avancer
encourager exhorté par leur chef
débordant d'énergie
les équipages de charme et et les
bouchées doubles
la france blindé de la division était
constituée du bataillon de chars épaulé
par l'artillerie équipé du terrible
canon de 88 mm entier rien désormais
utilisé avec succès comme canon antichar
et tracté au front par des camions des
semis chenilles et montés sur les
remorques
le 88 pouvait être déployée rapidement
et était capable d'engager l'ennemi à
plus de 2000 mètres bien avant que les
canons des chars alliés puisse riposter
le 88 avait un autre avantage au delà de
sa portée et de sa capacité à percer le
blindage
ils pouvaient aussi tiré des obus
explosifs
les panzers 3 et 4 pouvait aussi utilisé
des obus explosifs qui s'avérait
dévastateur contre l'infanterie mais
sans effet contre les chars britannique
comme le cruiser et le vallon time
derrière les premiers succès de rebelles
dans son avancée vers l'est résidait sa
ferme conviction qu'il était capable
d'écraser les forces alliées et
d'avancer jusqu'à alexandrie et au canal
de suez
de là ils pourraient foncé vers le
caucase au sud de l'union soviétique
pour effectuer un mouvement en tenailles
assez classique afin d'apporter un
succès décisif aux forces allemandes
l'idée de rebelles de rejoindre le
groupe d'armées sud dans son avancée
dans le caucase en passant par l'egypte
et la palestine itx est peut-être
considéré en 1942 comme une véritable
utopie pas bien des aspects cela
démontre la nature irréalistes des plans
stratégiques allemands pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale qui ne se
réalisera jamais vraiment contrairement
aux approches très pragmatique des
américains et des britanniques
les problèmes logistiques auxquels remet
elle aurait dû faire face et est immense
même s'il avait pu prendre le caire même
s'il avait réussi à traverser le delta
du nil ce qu'il aurait lui a tracé sa
route et traverser le canal de suez
il aurait également eu à combattre dans
l'école de medley et du délai à travers
le sinaï il réduit à faire face aux
mêmes problèmes que les britanniques en
1916 et 1917
lorsqu'ils ont combattu dans le sinaï il
n'y avait pas la moindre chance qu'une
grande jonction stratégie plus se mettre
en place
hitler avait fait le bon choix en
nommant romel bien qu'il est eu quelques
habitudes particulière le haut
commandement allemand avait été clair il
était là en premier lieu pour bloquer
les alliés puis mener une contre
offensive afin de reprendre la
cyrénaïque
mais toujours sous l'autorité du
commandant suprême italien les relations
entre romain et les italiens ont été
généralement mauvaises je pense qu'ils
les méprisait lorsqu'il fut nommé en
afrique le général italo gariboldi était
supposé être son supérieur hiérarchique
mais romaine ne te n'est généralement
pas compte de ces instructions
mais il ne faut pas oublier que romaine
ne tenait pas non plus vraiment content
d instruction des officiers supérieurs
allemand était très sceptique à propos
du haut commandement italien et frau en
particulier concernant la qualité des
officiers l'italien ils ignoraient le
commandant suprême italien ayew il
informait à l'occasion de ce qu'il
faisait
mais la plupart du temps non l'hôtesse
qu'à bord il partait et agissez seuls
les rangs italiens qui remet elle a
toujours pris au sérieux étaient les
hommes qui travaillaient sur les peurs
de naples et de la côte italienne il
jouait un rôle vital pour lui en
ravitaillant ces unités ne sais pas ce
que hitler n'avait pas anticipé c'est le
succès de rebelles dont l'aide aux
forces italiennes se transforma
rapidement en une série d'offensives
réussi hitler avait pensé l'afrika korps
comme un rempart un appui dans le cadre
du pacte de lax mermet le transforma en
vagues conquérante faisant sa propre loi
en dépit d impressionnante victoire de
rebelles il avait toujours des
difficultés relationnelles avec les
officiers du haut commandement allemand
sans doute amplifié par le fait qu'il
n'était pas un officier issu de
l'aristocratie prussienne et n'avait
jamais été membre de l'état-major
général d'hitler
rebelles pouvaient être rugueux sûr de
lui et dogmatique mais c'était avant
tout un brillant chef de guerre
romel mettre du mouvement fluide de la
bataille était prêt à prendre des
initiatives et à exploiter les
faiblesses de l'ennemi il était attaché
au principe éprouvé de la charge de
cavalerie légère destinée à semer la
confusion dans les rangs ennemis
il ne fait aucun doute que romaine avait
des failles comme commandante
il était dur très ambitieux et parfois
trop optimiste dans des situations qui
ne l'autorisaient pas il était sans
aucun doute assez égocentrique il fut
aussi le créateur de sa propre légende
finalement je pense qu'il a mené ses
hommes son matériel et l'équipement dont
il dispose est probablement trop
durement pour atteindre ses objectifs
ce qu'il a rendus vulnérables par fois
aux contre attaques rebelles n'a jamais
compris la relation qu'il y avait entre
la logistique et le combat en première
ligne ils reprochaient constamment à ses
intendant de ne pas lui fournir le
matériel dont ils avaient besoin pour
gagner ses batailles
il ne réalisait pas bien sûr qu en
étirant le ferons aussi loin il rendait
le travail logistique vraiment très
difficile par ses premières attaques
éclairs contre les alliés rebelles
réussi à prendre bengazi et la
cyrénaïque
ces forces submergeait re la base
logistique britannique de tobrouk et à
tenir le golf de solo mal est le général
rebelle était ici et là partout ces
colonnes blindées foncé à travers le
désert
partout sauf dans son quartier général
il restait en contact avec lui grâce à
la radio
mais lorsque les communications étaient
impossibles la cohésion de son arme et
s'affaiblissait après son succès face à
la contre-offensive britannique
l'opération battle axe remet l'écriviez
à son épouse lucie
j'ai passé trois jours sur les routes à
faire le tour du champ de bataille la
joie de mes soldats était extraordinaire
un de ses officiers remarqua il est déjà
en train de devenir un héros et il
devint un héros est une légende
adulé par ses hommes et redouté mais
respecté par ses ennemis
le début de la légende de remettre mon
peut-être en partie à winston churchill
qui se référaient à rebelles dans
l'appelant par son nom à la chambre des
communes formant un p chrome elle avait
fait sensation en 1941
mais les troupes britanniques le
considérait comme le renard du désert
presque un magicien de la guerre qui
arrivait toujours à les battre nous
voulons respecter et se nomma le général
montgomery qui avait une personnalité
presque similaire pour donner un nouvel
espoir aux troupes britanniques du
désert une des premières décisions
qu'ils prient fut d'interdire que le nom
de rebelles soit utilisée pour les
communications officielles quoi qu'il
arrive quand vous pouviez utiliser force
de l'absence vous pouviez dire l'ennemi
mais le nom de rebelles ne pouvait plus
être utilisé c'était significatif de la
part de montgomery car il souhaitait
être l'homme de la situation et avaient
l'intention d'écrire sa propre légende
david le fit en effet avec succès
lorsqu'il s'empare a finalement de
tobrouk le général rebelle fut promu au
rang de film marshall le plus haut rang
de l'armée
il avait juste 49 ans au mois d'août
1942 mêmes rebelles commencent à montrer
des signes de fatigue causée par ces 18
mois d'action ininterrompue et de
combats incessants
son énergie seul n'était plus suffisante
pour tenir il souffrait de violentes
douleurs gastriques et lui arrivait de
s'évanouir
or il était sur le point d'affronter son
plus grand défi la viiie armée
britannique
sous le commandement de montgomery à el
alamein en septembre il s'envola vers
l'allemagne pour être soigné quelques
semaines plus tard montgomery débuta son
offensive et hitler exigea par câble le
retour de rebelles en afrique du nord
romell retourna donc en afrique mais
avec de sombres pressentiments sans
illusion sur hitler et son attitude
envers les courageux soldats de l'afrika
korps
le monde avait changé il était loin le
temps où on remet les sons afrika korps
encore inconnus avaient reçu l'ordre
d'établir une défense agressive
il savait qu'il devait prendre
l'initiative sur l'ennemi
il devait transformer une retraite en
offensive il devait reprendre du terrain
et faire la démonstration aux
britanniques que désormais lorsqu'il
combattrait l'afrika korps il serait
face à un opposant vraiment très
différent des italiens avant c était à
l'ordre du jour et après avoir pris
tripoli en février ils furent ensuite
confrontés aux forces britanniques
il repousse r d'abord vers el aguila
puivert bardia et ce loup mâle est de la
libye ont assez rapidement
essentiellement grâce à une série de
mouvements d'encerclement par tant de
l'intérieur des terres vers la côte et
nous couper les liaisons et isoler la
8ème armées britanniques mai 1941 les
forces de rebelles se tenait aux
frontières égyptiennes avec seulement la
forteresse de tobrouk derrière elle
comme aiguillon dans leurs flancs ce fut
une écrasante victoire que les
britanniques n'avaient pas anticipé dans
leurs tentatives ultérieures pour
déloger romel de la frontière et
rejoindre tobrouk lors des opérations
previti mba thorax
les hommes de romain furent capables de
repousser les offensives britannique
remet elle fut forcé d'abandonner tout
ce qu'il avait gagné en 1941
car l'opposition de la viiie armée se
renforcer l'opération gravity et en juin
l'opération cruise adore ne furent pas
de grand succès pour les alliés mais
infligèrent cependant des pères d'art e
mail ce ne fut pas avant l'opération
battlax en novembre 41 d'une
réorganisation de la huitième année fut
capable de repousser rebelles et à ce
moment là 8e armés s'étaient
considérablement renforcés devant en
termes d'hommes et de blindés a trop mal
c'était au bout d'une ligne
j stick est tendue à l'extrême la france
les ratios étaient défavorables à romell
papa n'est qu'en novembre 1941 le
premier rapport de reconnaissance qui
lui arrive à à propos de l'avancé
britannique disait qu'il ne pourrait pas
croire l'importance des forces
britanniques qui avançait alors contre
lui un des messages 809 de
reconnaissance survolent à la colonne le
pilote lança son chronomètre et l'arrêt
talent lorsqu'il est atteint la queue de
la colonne il s'était écoulé dix minutes
et il volait à environ 500 kilomètres
cette information qui fait donner à
rebelles les britanniques qui arrivait
et en anglais j'ai bien sûr les
britanniques étaient plus nombreux que
les allemands et les italiens à deux
contre un et face aux seules forces
allemandes
le ratio était nettement plus élevé ce
qui est remarquable à propos des
campagnes de novembre et décembre 41
sait comment rmel a été proche de
stopper l'avancée britannique
c'est une des plus brillantes manoeuvre
de tous les temps tu affrontes gremelle
fut battu à la fin forcés de battre en
retraite
mais il retira s'efforce presque intact
à où il avait simplement été dépassés
par le nombre
il combattait sur deux fronts car il
avait la garnison de tobrouk à l'arrière
fond s'il devait y maintenir un minimum
de force d'assaut
dans le même temps ils essayaient de
tenir face à d'importantes forces le
long de la frontière égyptienne à
ribemont
il a été capable de le faire avec succès
par deux fois en mai et encore une fois
en plein été pendant l'opération battle
danny kent ça m'a presque un rebelle fut
forcé de battre en retraite en décembre
1941 après l'une des plus terribles et
sanglantes batailles de la guerre du
désert
les britanniques lancèrent l'opération
crouzade heures pour libérer tobrouk le
5 novembre 1941 un confort et bien
surprendre romaine et l'afrika korps par
surprise en raison d'une série de
combats terribles et sanglant
particulièrement en cyrénaïque
c'est la puissance des deux belligérants
la viiie armée l'afrika korps
s'effritait forme
cependant ce début décembre 41
il était clair pour remède après sa
tentative avortée défrayer la viiie
armée et de la faire battre en retraite
pour reprendre le contrôle des
opérations que la puissance de l'afrika
korps ne lui permettrait pas de tenir
très longtemps
il décida de reculer jusqu'à sa ligne de
départ d'avril 1941 nation pour
reconstruire ses forces vives et lancé
une nouvelle campagne en 1942 pour nike
france irlande à l'opération cruiser ne
reçut pas les félicitations qu'elle
méritait de recevoir c'était une
victoire britannique mais une victoire
très chèrement remporter mais elle a
certainement montrer que la viiie armée
et son commandant le général aoun chine
ne pouvait affronter raw mais laissons
afrika korps
le 7 décembre 1941 avec seulement 40
chars encore en ordre de bataille
romel décida d'un repli tactique lui et
ses hommes voulaient survivre pour
pouvoir reprendre le combat plus tard
les forces de l'axé reculèrent passèrent
tobrouk perdant bengazi pour de
nouvelles lignes de défense préparer de
marada à marsa el brega
bien qu'il fût désespérément à court de
ravitaillement rebelles commençaient à
sa contre-offensive l'afrika korps
attaque a une fois de plus la huitième
armées alliées fut repoussée à l'est
vers la frontière égyptienne rebelles se
lance à la poursuite des forces
britanniques à mesure qu'elles se
repliait pour préparer leur position est
là la marne et les deux batailles pour
el alamein allait décider du sort de
toute la campagne d'afrique du nord
alors que l'afrika korps rebelles foncé
vers l'est avec succès il tourna
brièvement au nord en 40 heures de
combat contre la garnison qui s'y
trouvait depuis huit mois
il prit finalement tobrouk fille 33
mille prisonniers et sans parade énorme
stock de fournitures diverses
le 21 juin 1942 remet le prix tobrouk
son port et sa forteresse vtt comme une
épine dans le pied pendant l'année 1941
we want ce fut réellement le point
d'orgue de sa carrière à partir de l'as
rome elle fut capable de mettre la
pression à l'ouest sur el alamein là où
il cherchait à faire une percée depuis
un moment
lors de la bataille d'el alamein
quelques mois plus tard face au nouveau
commandant de la 8ème art mais
montgomery
ban qui lança son attaque 5 octobre
après avoir réussi à obtenir une
supériorité en termes de matériel canon
avions soldats de trois contre un
rebelle fut contraint à subir une guerre
d'usure
real est stoppé à proximité d'el alamein
rebelles réclament a désespérément des
approvisionnements en pétrole et en char
il s'attendait à une percée de la viiie
armée et il ne perdit pas de temps à
créer des positions défensives pour
empêcher une telle attaque un peu de
carburant et quelques blindés arrivèrent
mais rien comparé à la pléthore de
troupes de chars de canons qui furent
acheminés jusqu'à la 8ème armées
désormais sous les ordres du prudent
montgomery prudent car montgomery
n'avait pas l'intention de se lancer
dans une offensive sans préparation il
attaquerait lorsque tous ces éléments
seraient en place et pas avant c'est en
octobre 1942 que monty fut finalement
prêt et commencer à son attaque à la
tête d'une force incroyablement
supérieur au nombre
une attaque qui allait marquer le début
de la fin pour l'afrika korps
sous les assauts répétés de la viiie
armée britannique
les panzers furent obligés de reculer
encore et encore vers l'ouest d'octobre
42è février 43 l'afrika korps furent
pousser des ailes à la marne puis hors
de la libye jusqu'à la tunisie en
tunisie romain appris que le plan allié
opérations torche menaçait ses arrières
des renforts urgent comprenant la
division parachutiste permane goering et
les premiers chars tigre furent envoyés
en afrique depuis l'allemagne par avion
attaquants en conjonction avec ses
troupes rebelles risquent à sa fidèle
21e panzer division qui tomba sur des
troupes américaines qui ne s'attendait
pas à ça ici dans le défilé de kasserine
où la bataille commence à le 14 février
le succès initial de la taxe à vera être
la dernière victoire de rebelles en
afrique et il réussit à obtenir l'effet
de surprise
ex crainte ce fut une première opération
brillamment exécuté et c'est un des
défauts de rebelles en tant que général
il tenta de capitaliser sur son succès
initial
au delà de ses limites en ressources
c'est ce qui s'est passé à kasserine qui
ne l'est pas
il repousse à la première armée
américaine et inflige à de sérieux
dommages à l'une de leurs divisions
blindées mais une contre attaque menée
par les britanniques et montra qu'il
n'était pas en mesure d'exploiter les
opportunités qui auraient pu être
obtenue face aux américains la défaite
américaine à kasserine eu un impact dans
toute la ramification de la structure
des forces américaines quand il était
arrivé à la guerre en croyant disposer
de toutes les réponses possibles pour
affronter les armées allemandes et leurs
blindés se retrouvèrent soudainement
prise au dépourvu c'est ici à medenine
turmel mena sa dernière bataille en
afrique en dépit de la qualité de ses
positions préparé par les français pour
résister aux offensives italiennes
contre leur territoire l'afrikakorps de
rommel avait perdu sa mobilité et son
soutien est rien
en dépit d'une résistance acharnée ils
furent rapidement débordé par les
troupes alliées à la bataille de
medenine rebelles compter sur l'effet de
surprise pour gagner mais montgomery
avait achevé ses préparatifs étaient
capables de contenir une attaque
conjointe des allemands et des italiens
l'attaqué fut repoussée en fait sans la
perte d'un seul char britannique remet
elle fut dominée par montgomerie qui
encourage à l' attaque contre cette
position de défense 100 canons antichars
et détruisit 50 chars allemands ester en
il était donc pris en étonner quand plus
tard en mars
il fut rapatrié en allemagne pour
soigner sa maladie et sa prévention
successeur fut tué dans un bombardement
d'artillerie est le suivant se retrouva
face à une armée deux fois plus
importante que la sienne
ils allaient attaquer 1200 ch a rallié
alors qu'il ne disposait lui que d'une
centaine de chars ce qui lui laissait
bien peu de chance l'échec de medenine
marquer la fin de l' empire italien en
afrique du nord
mais rome elle voulait au moins sauver
les restes de son armée pour garder
l'espoir de maintenir une sorte de tête
de pont en mars 1943 à medenine se
déroule à la dernière attaque majeure
allemande en afrique du nord contre les
forces surpuissante de la viiie armée et
les choix le jour même
en moins de deux mois toutes les forces
de l'axé avait capitulé et 150 mille
soldats allemands marchèrent la tête
haute
vers la captivité sourds aux mails la
première unité formée avec l'unique
intention de remonter le moral des
troupes italiennes fut la cinquième
légère rebaptisé la 21e panzer division
plus tard renforcée par la 15e division
de panzers et la 90e
une division légère les forces
allemandes en afrique du nord désormais
passé dans l'histoire sous le nom de
l'afrika korps ne fut reconnue sous ce
nom qu'un court laps de temps
alors qu'elle se développait l'afrika
korps ce fut appelée panzer groupe
africa incorporant si division italienne
en 1942 les troupes de rommel changèrent
à nouveau pour s'appeler panzer army
africa en incorporant deux des divisions
originale de l'afrika korps ainsi que
deux divisions d'infanterie allemande
une brigade aéroportée et 8 division
italienne
alors que les hommes de l'afrika korps
se combattaient à travers les immensités
désolé du désert rebel avait maille à
partir non seulement avec les forces
britanniques mais aussi avec ses chefs
en allemagne l'intérêt d'hitler pour
l'afrique du nord à l'est de la froide
indifférence à l'indécision en passant
par l'exigence folle vers la fin de la
guerre du désert de combattre jusqu'au
bout
il était aussi responsable d'un autre
handicap de l'afrika korps car sous
l'insistance de mussolini
elle était sous commandement italien
romel bien que toujours parfaitement
correcte avait assez peu de
considération pour les capacités
militaires de ses camarades italiens
en volant monde bien que remet elle fut
normalement sous le commandement des
italiens il était bien sûr assez
désobligeant à propos de ses supérieurs
italien le général bosco par exemple
était surnommé par hommel le général
bombasse tico tico bien qu'il accepta
d'être subordonnée aux italiens on
pratique ces rebelles qui menait la
danse le dernier regroupement des forces
de l' axe sur 20 en février 1943
lorsqu'il reçut le nom de groupe
d'armées d'afrique deux ans après que
l'afrika korps d'origine était formée
avec le maréchal rommel à sa tête la
formation de l'afrika korps avait drainé
des hommes de différentes zones en
particulier de nombreux hommes de la 90e
division légère qui avait précédemment
servi dans la légion étrangère française
durant son expansion l'afrika korps
avait monté une unité spéciale de
troupes de choc un peu dans la lignée
des longues robes désert groupe
britannique
il s'agissait du thunder verband 288 ou
unité spéciale 288 formés pour opérer à
l'intérieur des lignes britannique et y
mener des opérations contre les
exploitations pétrolifères ils portaient
eux aussi le brassard blanc de l'afrika
korps et comme leurs camarades ils
combattirent sous les ordres d'un
certain nombre d'officiers supérieurs
mais c'est le nom de rebelles qui les
reliait de façon indéfectible à l'afrika
korps roma l'été désormais un homme
affaibli et sans illusion qui avaient
reçu l'ordre de quitter son africa corse
bien aimé le 9 mars 1943 il s'envola
pour l'europe
désespéré à l'idée de la fin inéluctable
de cette aventure
hitler lui refuse le droit de retourner
en afrique où ces hommes désormais sous
le commandement du général von arx mines
continuer à se battre
les forces de l'axé battaient en
retraite en tunisie et vers enfidha
ville 50 km au sud de la péninsule du
cap bon entre les montagnes et la mer
là la 90e division légère centerra
autour des collines tandis que la 21e
panzer division se préparait à affronter
la tête de l'avant ses alliés pendant
les premiers jours de mai une bataille
d'artillerie féroce et des bombardements
aériens intensifs dévastèrent les
positions allemandes la 15e panzer fit
une tentative désespérée pour ne pas
être submergé par les forces alliées
qu'il est débordé les canes en tirèrent
jusqu'à épuisement des munitions
les chars à court de carburant
continuèrent à tirer là où il se
trouvait jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
de munitions le rapport officiel du
groupe d'armées africaines conserver
jusqu'à nos jours rapporte simplement
l'essentiel de la 15e division de
panzers doit être considérée comme
détruites
au début du mois de mai lentement à
contrecoeur les drapeaux blancs de la
reddition commencèrent à apparaître dans
les mains des hommes auxquels hitler
avait demandé de combattre jusqu'au
dernier les alliés entrèrent
triomphalement dans tunis l'afrikakorps
de rommel avait vécu pendant deux ans et
trois mois
surpassée à court de matériel en
infériorité numérique mais rarement pris
à défaut l'afrika korps avait écrit
quelques pages
parmi les plus glorieuses de l'histoire
militaire allemande